in this video we'll talk about the
vitamin b12 deficiency
we'll talk about what is the classic
symptoms of vitamin b12 deficiency and
what the harmful effects
vitamin b12 also known as
cobalamine is a water-soluble vitamin
used for metabolism
it contains cobalt and 4.3
percent by weight is cobalt in this
vitamin
it is a water-soluble vitamin and this
vitamin can be found from
animal
meat especially the red meat and liver
this is the principal source
other than that it can be found from
fish
leafy greens and dairy products
daily requirement for vitamin b12 is one
to two micrograms per day for any
healthy individual but during pregnancy
the demand is higher and should be more
than 2 microgram per day
all women who want to get pregnant
should consume a lot of vitamin b12 and
folic acid because both these vitamins
work hand in hand to perform a important
cellular task known as the neural tube
closure and neural tube closure is super
important for the development of the
embryo
if neural tube closure doesn't happen
properly
then there is problem in the brain
development and everything is happening
within the first trimester
so before even somebody know that they
are pregnant
these events are happening
so this is how a normal closed neural
tube look like but when there is a
deficiency of folate or vitamin b12
it can lead to conditions like
anencephaly spina bifida etc
so if you want to learn more about
neural tube defect and vitamin b9
deficiency you can click on the i button
anyway let's talk about vitamin b12
deficiency in bit more details
so let's talk about what are the causes
and what is the consequence first let's
talk about the causes
the cause of vitamin b12 deficiency can
be twofold either there could be dietary
deficiency there could be also
pathophysiological reason for which the
deficiency occurred
so in dietary deficiency if we don't
consume enough amount of red meat liver
etc then we would be deficient of
vitamin b12
and that is why many vegan people
are actually deficient of vitamin b12
because plant sources doesn't have as
high as a
vitamin b12 compared to the animal
sources
now poor people around the world doesn't
have access to money to buy good quality
of meat in a daily basis that is why
most likely they could also be uh
deficient for vitamin b12 and that is
why the third world country is the
place where there are many people with
malnutrition and there is an overall
deficiency of vitamin b12
absorption of vitamin b12 is a complex
process
anyway there are two important steps for
example parietal cell secretes castles
intrinsic factor
which is important for the absorption
process further down the intestine
there are specific receptors which
actually binds to these uh
conjugated vitamin b12 and leads to its
absorption
now there could be problems in this
absorption process which might lead to a
problem
for example atrophic gastritis in which
your stomach lining get thinned is a
problem where you can't have vitamin b12
absorption
conditions that affect your small
intestines such as crohn's disease
celiac disease bacterial growth
parasitic infection all of this can
possibly
reduce the chance of vitamin b12
in the in this team alcohol consumption
and alcohol abuse is another
reason for which the vitamin b12
absorption might be abbreviated
other than that pernicious anemia is
another situation where the absorption
is disrupted
now we understood that what are the
causes of deficiency let's try to
understand what are the effects of
deficiency or what is what are the
pathological situations
first of all there are metabolic
consequences because vitamin b12 is
important for metabolism
several enzymes that are required for
important biochemical pathway use
vitamin b12 as a coenzyme
for example
isomerase
methyl transferase dehalogenase all of
these enzymes actually use vitamin b12
for their functioning
so in absence of vitamin b12 all these
enzymes
are kind of not optimally functional and
that leads to problem in many
biochemical pathways which lead to
overall problem in the body
vitamin b12 deficiency can cause
pernaceous anemia
so pernicious anemia means not enough
red blood cells are produced due to the
deficiency of vitamin b12 let me tell
you how
vitamin b12 is involved in the
maturation of the red blood cell
so maturation of the red blood cell
happens in the bone marrow so here
everything starts with the erythroblast
and from the erythroblast there are
several steps
of electro
electrocyte differentiation
now these steps are triggered by several
enzymes which require vitamin b12 as a
coenzyme so when this coenzyme is not
present these steps are abrogated and
the differentiation of rbc is not
optimum which lead to overall
net reduction in rbc and leads to
pernicious anemia
vitamin b12 deficiency might have a
overarching effect for example it can
change the epigenetic landscape let me
tell you how
epigenetic modification such as dna
methylation histone modification all
requires uh vitamin b12 in an indirect
fashion
anyway in terms of dna modification such
as methylation requires methyl
transferase enzyme which transfers the
methyl group from s adenosine methionine
to dna
now
these
s adenosine methionine need to be
synthesized
this is synthesized from methionine and
indeed methionine is synthesized
synthesized from homocysteine
the step that converts homocysteine into
methionine involves in the in involves
vitamin b12 vitamin b12 actually take
the methyl group from
n5 methyl thf and donates it to
methionine
now in absence of vitamin b12 we can
clearly understand what is going to be
happening
so the methyl group is trapped in n5
methylthf and homocysteine is never
getting converted to methionine or s
adenosine methionine so overall s ado
methionine concentration would be lower
that would be affecting dna methylation
and other epigenetic processes
so these are major issues with vitamin
b12 deficiency
now another important thing is dna
synthesis
let me tell you how tetrahydrofolate
gets converted to 510 methylene
tetrahydrofolate
and this is utilized for the generation
of
dtmp which is one com component of the
dna now without these nucleotides dna
synthesis can be abrogated
and in this process vitamin b12 takes
important role
again vitamin b12 deficiency can lead to
several gi problems let me tell you how
first of all
there are alteration of bowel mobility
there could be constipation
mild diarrhea etc but let's look at the
reason why vitamin b12 might lead to
gastrointestinal symptoms
so if we look at our intestinal lining
all the intestinal epithelial cell has a
very high turnover that means they are
dividing
every day
so
this high turnover cells require
specific
components of the dna
for division because before division
they have to replicate their dna
so this dna synthesis process is
abrogated when there is vitamin b12
deficiency as we have looked earlier
because dtmp cannot be synthesized in
absence of vitamin b12
so that means vitamin b12 deficiency
slows down the turnover rate in the
intestinal epithelia and that causes
many problems
vitamin b12 deficiency is sometimes
associated with neurological symptoms
pain numbness tingling sensation in the
hand and feet weakness lack of
coordination loss of the reflex all of
these things are expected in vitamin b12
deficiency
but the question is what is the cause of
these kind of neurological symptoms and
why does it occur
so let us understand that vitamin b12 is
important for normal functioning of the
nervous system
because it has role in myelin synthesis
so methyl melanoid gets converted to
succinylchoice
and this requires enzymes which use
vitamin b12 as a coenzyme so the general
theme is several important enzymes
utilize vitamin b12 as a coenzyme and
whenever there is a deficiency of
vitamin b12 all those important
processes are abrogated
now methylmalonyl coa gets converted to
methylmalonic acid
which is actually myelin destabilizer
in absence of
vitamin b12 this step is favored so a
lot of myelin destabilizer is produced
that leads to destabilization of the
myelin sheath that alters the synaptic
properties and the action potential
firing properties of the neuron
so how the deficiency of vitamin b12 is
diagnosed so let's look at that
so in lab there are several tests by
which it can be diagnosed first of all
from the patient's blood sample or from
the patient's serum sample elisa can be
done
also we learned that homocysteine
doesn't get converted into methionine in
absence of vitamin b12 right
that means there would be a lot of
homocysteine that can be secreted into
the urine
so in a urine analysis if we find a lot
of homocysteine in the urine that means
possibly that individual is suffering
from vitamin b12 deficiency
there are a couple of other tests for
vitamin b12 deficiency but in this video
we didn't review that in details
anyway the treatment option includes
obviously supplementation with vitamin
b12 but eventually the dietary
modification can also help consuming a
lot of products such as animal meat
animal
dairy products can improve your vitamin
b12 uh
gain daily but if there is a problem in
vitamin b12 absorption then there are
other treatments which are required and
modifying habits like reducing alcohol
consumption reducing smoking all these
can help
you can get many
notes flash cards etc in my facebook
page you can follow us on instagram and
all the handles are provided in the
description
you can support the channel using the
super thanks option in the right hand
side bottom corner you can contribute by
using paytm paypal or upi
you can find all my social media links
in the description also follow the
nerdmedic channel
for exclusive medical content and
mnemonics
he's a
channel link and all the social media
links are provided in the description as
well don't forget to comment see you in
next video